[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation Juan Enriquez is an
inspiration to a lot of people in
biotech or became interested in biotech
because of him who start to understand
how things move around in the world in
terms of national borders and things
like that books that you can see in
their introduction card and he is a
person who not only talks a good talk
but he invests he puts his money where
his mouth is and as great adventures he
has adventures I guess the one I most
Envy is when craig Venter was out
basically inventing metagenomics and
changing all of biology by finding out
what kind of microbes are in the ocean
and and shotguns sequencing them and and
coming up with a whole new science that
transforms everything else in biology
who else was on his sailboat the
sorcerer was wanna Rica's and he's here
tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
so California we should start in Spanish
we bring you a public service
announcement top of the eighth Red Sox
ten in Cleveland three not that
anybody's counting Stewart was kind
enough to say why don't you come give a
talk and you know you talked about this
months ago and he says you know let's
come up with a fun title mapping the
frontiers of knowledge and I thought nah
that's too arrogant it sounds like
you're gonna do too much so I tried to
simplify it we'll just talk about
mapping life what I'm gonna try and do
tonight is to try and tell you what we
know about mapping life where life is
how life is structured where we think
the edges of the known world are and
then I'm gonna get a non-controversial
territory like what that does to
politics and religion this is what our
early maps of life looked like right so
we really didn't understand life we were
kind of looking out of a hole and then
we crawled out of a hole and we were
able to see something that looks like
this and we're still not quite sure what
lives over the next ridge or the next
ridge this is a little bit like the
first maps of the Americas where you get
a little squiggle of the edge of Brazil
and a couple of islands and there's
nothing behind that which would be the
Admirals map on the first maps of the
Americas and as you think about life and
how life evolves and this wonderful man
who was one of my heroes this is a guy
who went out and wrote and studied for
decades and after writing and working
for decades he gets a letter from an
obscure island called Trinity near the
sullens from a nap save skier guy called
Alfred Russel Wallace and when he gets
that letter the letter basically has his
entire theory of evolution outlined
written and Wallace is asking whether he
would submit it for publication this is
about a week after Darwin's child died
Darlan thinks about it for about three
minutes and sends off the manuscript to
his friends at the Royal Institute with
a letter that says this guy could have
taken dictation on the stuff that I've
been thinking for decades he has
preempted my life work but he got it
first he gets primacy and he basically
took 20 30 years of life and mailed it
off and of course his friends had been
talking to him for 20 or 30 years so
they reached a compromise and what they
did is they read the Wallace and the
early Darwin - scripts together into a
small seminar room where about 20 people
were sleeping and that's how you came to
understand how things evolved and how
things work how things are structured in
trees of life and these are early note
books of course not always believed by
everybody
led to the first trees which started
branching species and so these are some
of the first maps of life as we
understood it and you know there's the
famous Darwin's finches and there's that
wonderful book by Winer which one appeal
it sir and it begins to give us an idea
of how evolution occurs not just in long
periods but in real time that led to
more and more complex classifications of
life and this is how we thought about
life until quite recently so there were
always nifty little taxonomist who would
sit in obscure museums in dusty desks
and really go out and find we're in this
little set of lines all this was what
the mapping of life has been doing
recently is it's been blowing these
things to pieces and it's articles which
I'm sure all of you have read like this
one
now obviously you're all interested in
endosymbionts which look absolutely
obscure but what this is telling you is
that you're beginning to find whole
genomes of smaller species inside larger
species like insects and there's a
series of these articles coming out so
the problem with this is then what is
the genome or the life code of an animal
because it used to be that you have
these nice well structured things but if
you start to find the gene code of the
thing down in the lower left in the
upper right then where does that gene
code fit into that tree and when you
start finding these things transcribed
again and again in these obscure things
what it does is it completely changes
our understanding and map of life and
you start getting maps of life which
lets you in on a little secret here's
the secret this is what a tree of life
begins to look like and all of a sudden
instead of understanding life is a
series of very defined trees and
branches and you know there's a common
trunk and then it goes up and everything
else you're now beginning to think of
life as this circle that is constantly
interchanging exchanging moving
modifying and changing gene code and
that's a very different form of life
because instead of thinking of life as a
tree we're beginning to think of it as a
star system were the various nodes on
the star constantly exchanging data
there was a wonderful doonesbury cartoon
once upon a time that asked a
creationist if he believed in evolution
and the person said why do you ask and
he said well because you've got
antibiotic resistant TB and if you don't
penicillin ain't gonna work so as we
begin to understand life if you came
here today to understand the secret of
life it turns out that life is code and
it's imperfectly transmitted code and
the frontier of knowledge is beginning
to understand how to map this code where
to map this code how this code works how
it exists and what it does and that's a
really neat mapping
project because there aren't a lot of
continents left to map but most of life
is left to map out there so Stuart and
Ryan and iya Wilson a series of other
wonderful people are out trying to
create an encyclopedia of life on the
planet and that is an absolute
worthwhile endeavor because we have even
started to scratch this stuff on the
sorcerer expedition that Stuart men
mentioned that Venter and a series of
other Pirates were on we basically
double the number of genes and proteins
known on earth simply by sailing around
the world and sampling surface seawater
every 200 miles and any one of your kids
can go out and do really experiments
that are quite extraordinary this
answers the age-old question because all
life turns out to be made of four little
base pairs which come together in a
spiral staircase four rungs adenine
theanine guanine cytosine and what we're
beginning to do in these maps is were
beginning to try and map what this code
does and how this code is structured
using various fancy instruments so this
is a type of high end laser that breaks
down photons and if you shoot it at life
forms you can break down a whole series
of the images of these things it's like
a super telescope it's quite
extraordinary it's absolutely incredible
images you can't really see it up here
but some of the things you're getting
out of this material are wonderful this
is a nuclear magnetic resonance machine
you have to be really careful when you
walk into this room because if you have
anything metallic it will be drawn very
fast towards these magnets it is not a
good place to walk in with a black
barrier with a pocket full of change but
what you can do with this machine is you
can take a sample of urine you can break
it down and you can start to find Peaks
in different human cancers so this
becomes a high-end diagnostic machine
that starts to break down the chemicals
in your body in a non-invasive way
this is the more common way of
understanding and mapping the frontier
of life so these gene sequencing
machines can generate about 200 million
letters of new gene code every 24 hours
to do that you're looking at a layer of
about eight different corridors about
this size and machines that are three
hundred thousand bucks apiece
these are some of the largest databases
on the planet they're growing faster
than computers can keep up the storage
of those devices so computer storage
doubles about every 18 months this
doubles about every 12 months and
there's going to be an interesting
crossover point between IT and life code
where we're not quite sure how to catch
up and part of the reason why that's
going to happen is because of the gene
sequencing meeting that took place three
days ago in San Diego whole series of
the people who make this machine showed
up to show off their new toys if you can
imagine eight corridors of these
machines that get substituted by one
machine that looks like this you're
beginning to look at single desktop
machines that'll generate about a
billion letters of gene code in a single
run this is heading very quickly towards
a ten thousand dollar human genome that
means that likely is not every baby born
in the United States will come out of
the hospital with a full gene code and
we'll have to start understanding what
the map of his or her genome begins to
mean there were three competing machines
at this particular show three weeks ago
you had the first published human
diploid genome reason why this is an
interesting adventure is because DNA
replicates by splitting so when you
think of that spiral staircase a always
goes with T C always goes with G and
when DNA replicates it works like a
zipper so this side goes off one
direction the other direction
gets copied and you have two copies of
the same stuff and that's how your cells
grow and are made because DNA replicates
that way when the first human genomes
were mad
in 2001 everybody thought if I take half
the genome 3.2 billion letters as
opposed to 6.4 billion letters the other
will simply be a mirror image that turns
out to be false
so this gentleman Venter sequenced his
own genome and when he sequenced his own
genome he found this stuff this is about
three weeks old the original 2001 map is
up on top and the new genome map for the
same region is down below and it turns
out that human beings are an awful lot
more complicated than we thought with an
awful lot more variants than we thought
of course you know that because you've
lived with your brother or sister these
maps are going to change the way in
which we think about medicine that we
think about nutrition that we think
about why some people live long why some
people are cured and some people aren't
this code is coming at you and
accumulating in an absolutely
extraordinary fashion and we're just
mapping this stuff these are the first
outlines of these continents we haven't
even gotten to the point where we
understand the continent as it's there
yet these are just the bare outlines of
these little islands a single gene
change will mean a difference of two
hundredfold in body weight in the same
species
so yes which cassette you insert really
does matter and as you look at this
stuff what's really neat about it is how
fast it's spreading so this is a science
Children's Museum in Minnesota and
you've got people working on cheek cells
and you've got people working on giant
chromosomes and the kids will isolate
the chromosomes and image them and
they'll go out and they'll start to
understand particular gene sequences and
they're learning this stuff and
unfortunately not everything is working
well in this museum you still have to
post signs that look like this and of
course I'd argue this is probably not a
sign that you should have to tell people
in a Children's Museum but
we're entering a period where we're
gonna start prescribing thinking about
our own bodies in terms of our own
gingka our own protein code or ailment
metabolic code this is a very very
different era it's an era where we're
gonna move from a medicine which is a
binary medicine you're sick you're not
sick take a medicine don't take a
medicine into an era where you are
handed a probability curve that tells
you you're not sick but here's your
lifetime chance of getting Alzheimer's
or breast cancer or colon cancer or this
or that or the other problem number one
most schools don't do a very good job of
teaching arithmetic just look at the
federal deficit second problem if they
don't teach arithmetic they don't teach
probability and doctors in the 15
minutes that they see you aren't going
to have the time to explain probability
theory to you and even if they have the
chance to explain probability theory on
a specific condition like breast cancer
because you've got a bracket one or a
bracket two mutation or a p53 mutation
they're not going to have the time to
explain a phone book with 60,000
probability curves in it which is what
comes out of a single gene chip today
and oh by the way this information is
changing every week this is good for you
no no no turns out it's bad for you this
is really dangerous but only in
conjunction with these other five
factors tune in next week it will change
we're moving from an era of relative
certainty in medicine in nutrition in a
whole series of things into an arrow of
probabilities uncertainties and constant
change and a lot of the way in which
we've been teaching doctors and teaching
engineers and stuff it's going to drive
that type of mental personality
absolutely crazy all right these are
people who want to know when memorize
the answer in the book and that's how
they get tested and that's how they get
graded and that's how you go through
your G mats and that's how you go
through engineering and we're going to
have to think long and hard about what
we do with education because this is a
very different type of mindset
let me move now from sort of the gene
code the absolute micro the nano scale
into what's happening in a similar field
a couple of chains up the ladder so you
go from gene code a TCG up into proteins
and then you go into the execution of
stuff in tissues and then you get to
organs here too were beginning to enter
some really interesting areas we're
beginning to map to stuff in a very
different way so this is one of the
first great cartographers and mapmakers
south african surgeon interesting
personal life opponent of apartheid who
went out and did the first heart
transplant the second heart transplant
he did was mixed-race which in South
Africa at that time was not an easy
thing to do but when he did the first
heart transplant one of the questions he
went out and started asking is did the
person who receive the heart fall in
love with the relatives of the donor why
would he ask a question like that
because there was no map you had no idea
and for 2,000 years you've been telling
people I gave you my heart she broke my
heart she took my heart da da da da
so we thought emotion resided in the
heart I have a heart ache of course
eventually we learned through things
like this that the heart turns out to be
a muscle but you don't translate or
transport emotion in a heart and as you
go forward one of the really interesting
things is happening in this map is how
many disciplines that are academic
disciplines are coming together to
create images of what is a muscle this
is a centre in Canada and the really
interesting thing is it's combining
things which in a traditional University
never see but in a new University you
can do it because you don't have these
stovepipe departments so it's the new
universities that are putting together
vascular hearts biology completely
different discipline molecular go down
to the bottom level imaging well that's
the province of radiology and here
you've got five completely different
academic disciplines coming together in
a single Center
this is really interesting stuff and
this is the stuff that's gonna make for
mergers this is a stuff that's gonna
make for new knowledge because you're
going to get people with completely
different ideas and disciplines and ways
of looking at the world coming together
to begin to understand something like
the heart one of the interesting things
they're doing here is this wonderful man
learn how to keep hearts alive so this
whole apparatus the purpose of this
apparatus is to keep a tiny mouse heart
alive for weeks and it's a little
disconcerting because you walk in and
there's this little tiny heart that's
kind of beating there but you can now
keep hearts alive outside the body and
in fact if any of you're squeamish you
should probably close your eyes just
like a roller coaster but you can now
start to put hearts inside machines this
is a wonderful picture from National
Geographic let me show you what these
machines do active in a special machine
until it was ready for transplant
now it's hoped the procedure can be
repeated for all kinds of organs the
pictures of the beating heart are simply
extraordinary but also graphic health
correspondent Sewell reports
this is how organ transplants have been
achieved by keeping the donated organ in
a chill box but now this pioneering
organ care system could dramatically
increase the number of viable organs
available representing something of a
transplant revolution the rhythmical
beat of life but this beating heart is
outside the body
artificially pumping a pulse into the
organ not science fiction but science
fact
doctors at Papworth and hare field
hospitals believe it could make many
more organs available we believe that
using this machine in reducing the total
amount of time that the heart is not
being supplied with blood and therefore
limiting the deterioration and damage to
the organ that will one reduce the early
failure rate of grafts because there is
a frequency which grafts don't function
well or even don't start at all in
addition we'll be able to go further to
recover organs because we won't have the
time clock as much of an issue when a
heart is donated it's a race against
time
normally the organ is removed and
chilled in ice to slow down the rate at
which cells die the heart must be
transplanted within four hours for the
best chance of success
this means it can't always be fully
medically assessed it also limits how
far the heart could be transported but
this revolutionary technique is changing
that to a 12 hour time limit now the
organ can be kept beating by a mobile
heart-lung machine using the donors
blood and oxygen
it keeps the heart warm ensuring cells
are kept alive so organs can be
medically assessed and transported
further there were a hundred anyway you
get the general idea of this we're gonna
start working on a whole series of other
parts of the body and we're gonna start
thinking about keeping various parts of
the body alive but this is moving pretty
quickly
this week you had this announcement so
what these folks are able to do is
they're able to differentiate cells not
even take heart cells but take skin
cells
and begin to build a series of blood
vessels out of skin cells so when you
think of how do you rebuild all the
veins or arteries of somebody who's been
in an accident or have been burned or
has eaten too many McDonald's burgers
this may be one option this ability to
understand life to keep life alive in
different parameters to map life to be
able to differentiate life and guide
life is one of the most exciting single
explorations and maps and cartography
going on today a third set of
cartography that is quite interesting as
you start mapping life is this whole
notion of who we are and what we can do
so there was a period once upon a time
where you called folks like this
handicapped it is hard to do that these
days not just for political correctness
but because these guys are running with
various and sundry devices in races and
they're actually running pretty fast
this particular character is interesting
he holds the world record in the 400
meters in the Special Olympics
he's now gotten to the point where he is
within about half half a second of
qualifying for the Olympics with no
adjective not the Special Olympics and
he's creating a hell of a quandary for
the IOC for the International Olympic
Committee because he's asking to run
against able-bodied runners and it turns
out that maybe this year maybe in two
years maybe in five years folks like
this are gonna beat folks who are born
with quote-unquote normal legs this is
also moving forward into a whole series
of different parts of the body so it
used to be that when you were partially
deaf you'd have one of these massive
speakers that would look like an RCA
phonograph coming out you kind of listen
through that and then you got these
clunky machines that never worked and
then you got these tiny discrete
machines that went behind your glasses
and now you've got these little tiny
machines that you can't see almost at
all but even people who are profoundly
deaf are beginning to have machines
which are implanted into their bodies
and what we're seeing here is a
transmitter and a receiver stimulator
over here a speech processor over here
and a hole electrode array over here and
these things in its first iteration
allow people to begin to her primitive
sounds and about 18 months later you can
hear better and about 18 months later
you can hear better and it takes you
about a few hundred thousand years to
evolve to a higher plane of hearing it
takes the stuff about 18 months and at
some point these folks are going to be
able to hear stuff in tones that you can
hear it will have an accuracy in hearing
that will go beyond yours and you'll
probably start to see discrimination
suits in symphony orchestras when
somebody's not hired because they have
normal hearing this of course is also
beginning to happen with things like
eyes so as we begin to move through
these primitive areas where we start
transmitting images from cameras onto
chips into electrical impulses and
giving sight to the parsley or totally
blind again the stuff we're doing today
looks clunky and kludgy but as we start
mapping the frontiers of where this
stuff is going it's not inconceivable
that some of these folks will have
better eyesight than you or I here's a
couple of questions
ouch
right I mean part of what we've learned
over the past decades since Barnard
started transplanting things and part of
what this map tells you is the soul
doesn't reside in the heart it doesn't
reside in the kidney it doesn't reside
in the liver it doesn't reside in part
of the stomach it doesn't reside in the
intestine you can alter you can change
you can swap and the person doesn't
become more soulful or less soulful
so therefore the soul does not reside in
those particular body parts that leaves
one area and this to my mind is one of
the most interesting areas about the
study of life as we start studying life
on a molecular level and as we start
mapping life in a whole series of other
ways with photons and with magnetic
resonance the Restless stuff the black
box still remains the brain and it's
that study of the brain in various
machines in various ways that I think is
one of the single most interesting areas
of where things are being mapped and
again it's this interdisciplinary thing
that's going to ask a series of
questions there are some of the most
interesting questions sitting out there
how does life occur where does life
occur that's one segment of it on a
micro level but on a macro level on a
human level on an organ level the folks
doing this kind of research I think are
the great cartographers and this
research is taking place in buildings
that look like this this is something
that very few universities could do
because it's not a start-up University
this is MIT but what I'm I t's doing is
it's bringing together a whole series of
departments and they're not kicking and
screaming to try and stay autonomous in
this new building which ironically is
right across from the new robotics
Center is bringing together brain and
cognitive sciences and it's trying to
map the brain from psychology and
psychiatry and imaging and chemistry and
neurobiology and genomics and a whole
series of other things and some of the
conversations that will take place in
these hallways probably won't be very
relevant to venture capitalist for a
while but they will certainly be
relevant to the
people who are doing some of the most
interesting cartography on the planet
this is part of the frontier part of the
mapping of we're known life lies on a
macro scale of course you don't have to
wait for these buildings to be built
this is something that we saw it gadget
off about week and a half two weeks ago
and the interesting thing about this
particular robotic arm that DARPA is
funding is that it allows a series of
movements that become stronger and
stronger and more and more controlled
but usually these robotic arms have used
the muscles that are there to transmit
the instructions to the arm what's
particularly interesting about this arm
is this is using brain waves to control
that arm and we're beginning to link
those waves to the control of the arm
and that is an order magnitude different
from the some of the stuff that we've
been doing with prosthetics this is the
edge of the known world in terms of
transmission let's go back to the micro
for a second as we talk about life
here's something we found out about a
month ago life actually does happen and
it ain't that complicated so you have
this wonderful trio of unindicted
co-conspirators clyde Hutchinson
Hamilton Smith and craig Venter ham you
probably haven't heard of ham is one of
these gentle giants on the planet he's
one of the most wonderful human beings
he's also one of the most modest human
beings when he discovered restriction
enzymes which are ways of splitting
genes one of the things he got for that
was the Nobel he had been so modest
about what he was doing and working on
that he got a call from his mother mom
calls and says am I just heard on the
radio
somebody called ham Smith won the Nobel
I didn't know there was a second ham
Smith at Hopkins okay mom what these
three folks have been doing is they've
been trying to figure out can we begin
to operate cells as code and the
experiment that was published about a
month ago in science looks like this and
the reason why this stuff is very cool
is because they took entire strands of
DNA from one species inserted it into a
different cell and had the second cell
boot up as an entirely different species
talk about identity theft this is
actually for real and the fact that you
now have specific recipes and cookbooks
this was presented on Monday in San
Diego would you like to boot up another
species in your kitchen
well here's about what it takes and the
fact that that's what it takes means
that life happens and probably life is
very common not just here but probably
in a lot of different places which goes
back to that little secret life is
promiscuous and as you think about this
stuff what you're looking at in those
two blue cells with a different identity
for the different species is probably in
terms of economic power going forward of
economic change something similar to
this little gizmo which was the first
transistor as all of you know here the
reason why Silicon Valley exists is
because this particular man had a sick
mother moved back to take care of her
and he was so unpleasant and nobody
wanted to work with him for very long so
he had all these startup garages working
in different places because everybody
kind of got sick of him and went out and
did their own thing and built out the
whole atronics industry
this is what the first life transistor
looks like brand-new nobody's quite sure
what you're gonna do with it
like this one not terribly elegant but
boy is that gonna make a difference in
the world if you start to think of the
cell as hardware and gene code a
software now you can start programming
cells for specific purposes the first
thing that you're going to start seeing
is changes in places like the energy
markets why the energy markets well it's
a simple area it's easy to understand
you can containerize with stuff you
don't have to put it out in the
environment but you can do things like
start transforming coal all hydrocarbons
are basically concentrated sunlight
right so you put out a whole bunch of
solar panels called leaves or you put
out mats of bacteria that absorb the Sun
they concentrate the power of the Sun to
power the plant eventually they die they
rot under pressure for millions of years
and you spend a lot of money putting
pipes into the ground to bring the stuff
up then you put in another pipeline you
cross several countries you go into a
huge refinery to go through a primary
secondary and tertiary petrochemical
process and outcomes gas or outcomes
gasoline or outcomes polyester or
various chemicals we're now learning to
short-circuit this stuff and that will
make a difference it will make a
difference because we will able be able
among other things eventually to get
energy out of plants we already do that
it's called ethanol but the conversion
ratio is awful it may not even be
one-to-one but in the measure that we
begin to understand how life forms can
make energy because most life forms on
this planet haven't evolved so that
human beings can have more energy not
surprising we're going to start doing
the same thing that we do with our pets
with bacteria
see a house pet is a domesticated
parasite right you tried leaving your
little pet out there somewhere in an
African jungle and see what happens you
have to walk it every day you have to
feed it every day you have to pet it
every day it's evolved to have an
interaction with human beings same thing
with corn same thing is going to start
happening with energy and things like
bacteria we're going to start
domesticating bacteria to process stuff
inside and closed reactors to produce
energy in a far more clean and efficient
manner this is just the beginning stage
of being able to program life eventually
will reach medicine eventually we'll
reach a whole series of other things but
were many years away from that
that's the frontier and that's the map
of life so that's where life is heading
as life heads in this direction as the
cartographers discover these new
continents discovery of course has a
series of consequences because nations
rise and fall based on this stuff so
it's not just life that's evolving it's
also power that's evolving and as you
think of power traditional power was
based on things like this got soldiers
got weapons you be powerful other
sources of power well you could have God
on your side or you could have really
big government's on your side but how
your powerful and why you're powerful
today is changing in a fundamental way
and as you think about power today think
about how the old great empires were
built just before the Industrial
Revolution India and China were about 40
percent of the global economy until
recently they were about 3.4 percent
what happened to these great empires
that were able to build these absolute
wonderful palaces of marble well
technology and business passed them by
they focused on living in the hems they
focused on the beauty of poetry they
focused on the beauty of literature they
focused on the beauty of history of all
their accomplishments but they quit
building the acquit educating the quit
making new stuff the court learning new
stuff you were so focused on celebrating
the pleasure of today and the glory of
the past that their kids ended up
indolent not terribly smart and the
world passed them by
and this architecture over the course of
a relatively short period of time turn
into this architecture which is of the
course the architecture of a different
Empire because this little obscure
island on the edge of Europe did focus
on learning did focus on technology and
took over about 11 million square miles
of the world you learn you don't learn
you get these waves of technology you
don't get these waves of technology it
actually makes a difference in terms of
whether your country survives whether
your country's sovereign the really
interesting question in my mind isn't
how did India lose its independence and
sovereignty a really interesting
question to my mind these days
is how can a society that looks like
this today that has politics that makes
American politics look simple end up
with a ten percent growth rate on a
consistent basis and of course
the answer is a part of that is in
buildings like this this is what power
looks like today India doesn't have a
huge army India's got a politics that is
just messed up it has very little
infrastructure but this particular
building right here and this particular
building are part of the core of why
India is powerful this is the Bangalore
India Institute of Technology and what
these guys have done is they've been
able to educate the next generation to
the point where they are now the second
largest software provider in the world
and the impact of this originally is in
places like this where 40% of CEOs in
Silicon Valley or of Indian and Chinese
descent building a GDP is larger than
Indians but as you go forward this is
where it really makes a difference
because it's not just the elite that are
going to these schools it's not just the
6,000 that are on that campus
it's the kids in the street and the kids
in the street are carrying little
computers on their motorcycle and the
stuff they admire the stuff they like
they don't have logos of sports teams on
their helmets
these guys have Computer Associates on
their helmets and when you get a society
that's learning this quickly and
educating kids this quickly when you
land at the airport and you see
educational loans everywhere you see the
kids taking drugs but their drugs to
improve their memory not to lose it and
you start to see these little shops that
look like third-world shops but instead
of selling knickknacks and falafels and
restless stuff they've got the IBM
distributorship and right next to the
IBM distributorship you've got the cable
company the info tech company the
placement company the laptop company all
stacked one on the other all dreaming of
entering this digital world all
educating their kids to do this on em I
t's online courses let me contrast that
with what happened with the people who
first colonized India so one of the
first colonies in India is Goa the
Portuguese go out and pour colonize it
and then they keep going and they
eventually get to China and in Macau you
start getting these strange mixtures of
Chinese and Portuguese on all the
buildings but these were folks who
thought you know the natives are pretty
stupid we shouldn't teach them anything
we should just exploit them so we'll
focus on prostitution will focus on
gambling will focus on staying up above
we won't bother to learn Chinese and as
a result the most famous buildings are
buildings that are built on exploitation
this is one of the great monasteries
this is where vasco da gama is buried
wonderful statues of vasco da gama went
out went around africa opened the road
to the pacific I'm sorry to Asia
but because he didn't bother to and the
Portuguese didn't bother to deal with
the natives or educate the natives this
is the single most famous building in
Macau it is an empty facade and of
course you could see billboards like
this when you go to Portugal today it's
a little worn down now think about that
for one second if these folks had
bothered to deal with Hindi languages to
learn Chinese to train people to have
the kids of the Portuguese elite learn
these languages establish trade
relationships have a good relationship
with the people that they were
conquering colonizing teaching
missionarying what might have been the
consequences well this little tiny state
would have been the entrance for Chinese
and Indian goods and the bridge into
Europe much as Spain which has been one
of the most successful models has
recently learned to be a bridge to Latin
America but these folks never bothered
to learn how to speak Chinese or Indian
Hindi go to Portugal today walk through
the streets these are folks who
colonized China and India for centuries
find me a Chinese restaurant
I mean Indian restaurant hard to find
very different from London very
different from Paris where everybody who
goes around an Egyptian obelisk where
you go into one of the great museums of
the world and it's full of cultures of
other things and they're absorbing those
cultures here's an example of what would
have happened you've got a river coming
down the Pearl River on one bank you've
got Macau and right across from Macau
right on the other side of the river
there be Hong Kong the Brits were not
perfect colonizers by any means
but they did establish a civil service
they did estelle their schools they did
establish a sub a whole series of ways
of coming up through that system and
because of that there's an absence
extraordinary trade that went on between
Britain and continues to go on between
Britain and parts of Asia not always
easy not always pleasant but the
difference between the buildings in
Macau and these buildings is quite
significant and this is what that little
experiment led to it really matters how
you treat those who seem at this point
dumb or dispossessed or ignorant or poor
when I was in college you know there
were words like high tech there were
words like hard work there were words
like innovation there were words like
great universities and those did not
usually apply to Ireland but of course
today the Irish have higher income per
capita land do the Brits and are doing
an absolute extraordinary job real
estate in education in high-technology
in bridging the roads of the Americas
while Britain still trying to figure out
what went wrong this is what power looks
like in the u.s. today it's not the
Washington monuments it's not these huge
obelisks it's not the old or the new
memorials it's things that look like
this this is Jefferson High School I
went to this about three weeks ago in
Virginia this is what the hallways look
like nothing special about this place
they allow the kids to paint the roof
the tiles
except that all the backpacks are on top
of the lockers they don't have to be
locked up because every kid who's here
wants to be here because one out of six
kids gets picked for the school public
school
here are the kinds of projects these
kids are working on as juniors here are
some of the textbooks they're looking at
they're not textbooks because they're on
the edge and they're simply putting in
the articles as they come out this is
one of the most extraordinary teachers
who teaches at this place he and the
principal this place evan laisure have
generated more of what we used to call
westinghouse scholars and are now Intel
scholars than any school in the US kids
are writing from six different counties
of Virginia every day to come to this
place they've got a prototype shop
they've got a placement agent that makes
any school green with envy they have a
list of where all their kids go and
these are the kids who are going to MIT
and Caltech and Harvard and Yale and
Princeton Stanford UVA and Duke in the
rest of these places and what do you
walk outside you see something that you
very rarely see in a high school in the
US it turns out that we're all state
champs in debate and swimming and diving
and indoor track and cross-country oh
and by the way right alongside those
sports here's the academic championships
this is a school that's treating
academia in the same way as Texas high
schools treats Friday night football
you can hire coaches you can fire
coaches you reward excellence you have
to add a practices you don't show up you
leave you're there because you want to
and if other high schools in the u.s.
start treating academic academics in the
same way as many schools treat football
this will continue to be a more powerful
country but when you take this line out
of high schools you can get into trouble
very very quickly
right
when those kids graduate from high
schools they're not going to work in
buildings that look like the Hong Kong
buildings they don't go to work for the
fortune 500 for the most part oh and by
the way the fortune 500 has generated no
net new jobs in the past few decades in
the u.s. the new jobs come out of places
that look like this and you drive by and
you kind of say well you know that's a
lousy little building this is some of
the most expensive real estate as all of
you know in the United States
this is Sand Hill Road so this is where
you're incubating an awful lot of the
companies that we're talking about in
life sciences or that keep hearts alive
or that do microchips or that do this
that or the other now it's that basic
input of brains either imported or
generated that makes this little engine
run those little engines lead to
computer centers like this one this is
one little newest and largest computer
centers in the US this is the new Howard
Hughes facility in Genelia Farms in
Maryland and this is one of the centers
where life is going to be mapped studied
and structured and it's bringing
together the IT world with a life
science world in absolutely
extraordinary buildings this has a full
hotel it's got a lake right here your
hotel room looks out right on the lake
you've got a super computer facility I
will fund you generously as long as
you're secure Hughes scholar largest
structural glass building in the world
absolutely extraordinary Minds coming
together in a few places to map life as
you think of life being mapped and as
power changing a whole series of areas
of our lives are going to be changed and
sometimes I've talked about what it does
to chemistry companies or pharma
companies or biotech companies or
insurance companies or chip companies or
manufacturing companies or energy
companies but it even starts to change
things like religion
so to be completely non-controversial
let me bring together two words that
often go together
religion and evolution
that is a fact right species go extinct
and so to do religions do we have any
proof of this well this is what the
Sumerian religions look like and how
they evolved from being sky gods and to
air gods into wisdom gods into lady of
wine they were getting smarter here let
me in that an evil queen of the
underworld all kinds of things coming
together then there were these other
folks they thought you know if we don't
throw 20 virgins with their hearts cut
off off the top of this thing
maybe the Sun won't come up you put out
a thesis like that one day the head
priest sleeps in the 20 versions aren't
sacrificed the Sun comes up oops
a little bit of dissonance between what
you're saying and what happens and of
course we've worshipped gods of death
we've worshipped gods of the sea or gods
of the sky or gods of the rain or gods
of whatever the Mayans had hundreds of
these gods and here there was a common
argument this or these are the one true
gods we and we priests alone have
discovered the one truth you don't
follow this truth we will burn you we
will kill you we were eliminate you or
you will rot in hell because we and we
alone know the answer curiously enough
recent archaeological digs have found a
series of these gods of these priests
who used to use their power to hurt
people and to prove that their God was
the only true God this is what one of
these archeological digs looks like
here's a history of what we know about
single gods single gods were not very
popular over the hundred and fifty
thousand years that we've been here as
far as we know until about right here we
start getting things like Judaism and
Christianity and Muslims and Protestants
just to put this concept in a historical
framework of how this stuff is evolved
but we have now discovered the truth
depending on which part of the world
you're in the interesting thing is how
many of these things have common roots
and evolved from common roots so here
you've got this nice fellow Abraham who
actually is really important to these
three very different religions and if
you want to get a little bit closer and
more personal here is someone of the
Jewish religion who gives birth to early
Christianity until you've got a great
schism and then you get your first
evolution between the Greek and the
Russian Orthodox and the Roman Catholics
and then the Roman Catholics beget a
whole series of other things like the
version well a loop and a whole series
of different groups and then you get
this nasty fellow Luther who comes along
and he evolved and baguettes a whole
series of other things and then of
course a little more recently you've got
the Mormons coming out over here from
somewhere
but of course there's an evolution to
this stuff right in a lot of common
beliefs and a lot of common structures
and a lot of common thing isn't the
closer they are the more they seem to
fight there's a whole series of
questions that scientists I don't think
should be answering or trying to answer
at this point one of those questions
have to do with the WHO and the why of
the universe but scientists are and
they're actively and quickly mapping the
edges of life the edges of the known
universe the edges of power the edges of
the body the edges of how things are
done and when religions start to get
into the questions of how and what then
they get into real trouble because as
soon as you leave the realm of who and
why and move into the how and what you
can end up with some really nasty
surprises here's what one of these
surprises looks like right all of a
sudden you have a universe that revolves
around the earth and this nasty fellow
comes up with a telescope finds that the
earth actually revolves around other
things and he gets excommunicated for it
that fact
fortunately the Catholic Church knows
how to recognize its mistakes so it
recognized that Galileo was right in the
1990s
but he'll who's counting let's just put
a context on what we know about life and
what we think about these things these
days most of you have probably seen
these wonderful Hubble images right so
you have this wonderful nebulized
sitting out there the only thing that's
missing from this picture is a small
sense of scale so if you take these
three little columns that are sitting
right here in the middle and you take a
close-up picture say a family picture
this is what it looks like this is a
whole bunch of Stardust coming together
a coalescing and crunching to such an
extent that you get fission and what
you're watching here is the birth of
stars these are star nurseries just
giving off stars they're just being born
and sort of floating off into space and
again you don't quite get a sense of
scale remember these three columns are
basically right here when you look at
that one of these columns is about 57
trillion miles high you look at pictures
like this look at universe like this and
one of the things that you now know is
that the universe is about 13.7 billion
years old of course this keeps changing
here's one thesis on this stuff one
thesis is that the universe was created
13.7 billion years ago earth about 4.5
billion years ago life about 4.5 billion
years ago humanoids about 0.06 thousand
billion years ago and man came here
about 0.0015 and the purpose of this
particular machinery all these billions
of stars of a universe that looks like
this is so that we can be at the top of
the pyramid and we are the be-all and
end-all there is no other life in the
universe there is no other purpose to
the universe there's no purpose to the
billions of stars and the billions of
planets except
to reach an evolution in seven days or
in 13.7 billion days depending on what
you believe to the point where we can be
right about here and that's it oh and by
the way the purpose to all these other
protohumans the Australopithecus and the
erectus and the Lucy and the this that
and the other was to get to what's in
this room today that is a scary thought
but if that's not the purpose of life
and if we are not the be-all and end-all
of evolution then some of the questions
that we've been talking about tonight
about how you map life what happens with
life how does life occur what does life
do how does life evolve where is it
going and even how are we evolving
become really interesting and
fundamental questions and we should have
the honesty to ask those questions
without a whole series of prejudices of
hey God told me and he phone dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah dah
I didn't write that in closing here
would be a summary of the talk these are
what I think some of the new rules of
life are and they are incomplete and
this is a draft version and you are the
first to see this talk so I'm happy to
take comments are happy to alter it it
vastly oversimplified almost any topic
you want but he'll but some of the rules
that you can get out of this would be
these
it's this last point that makes this
stuff so interesting it's just last
stuff that makes you all cartographers
this is a particularly interesting place
to be discussing this because you're
right next to the UCSF campus because
you're right next to some of the places
where some of this research is taking
place so think of yourselves of citizen
as citizens of the Renaissance you are
sitting in front of the most
extraordinary intellectual discovery and
banquet of knowledge of opportunities of
ideas that anybody who's ever called
himself a human has ever sat in front of
we're doubling the amount of data
generated by the human species in the
next five years and all of you can do
this to have cafes to talk philosophy to
talk ethics to build companies to change
governments to change countries to
change education what would you like to
deal with this wonderful adventure of
mapping life because mapping life in
this cartography is in its very early
infancy and this is an absolutely
extraordinary period to be sitting here
to be alive it's like Christmas every
morning you get your new science
magazines you get your new articles you
get new books by some of the folks on
this room like Stewart Kevin Kelly and
it just fills you with joy it's just
wonderful because you learn stuff every
day you can build stuff every day you
don't have to [ __ ] about stuff every
day mapping life is going to change
every aspect of our lives it's going to
change our concept of religion of ethics
of business and of countries and
therefore I would argue in conclusion
but life is something's worth mapping
and it's worth mapping well so let me
put a period on the talk and that's the
end of story
for now anyway thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
question from Ellen where's Ellen we get
lights up a little bit in here does
private ownership patents and such
things of genomes or ideas stifle
innovation and while you're at it to
reconcile technological process progress
with a finite earth you know there's a
tyranny of unintended consequences and
throughout history you've seen these
wonderful notions of what fairness
should be and you get people who come
and they argue passionately you should
do something in a more fair fashion and
a few centuries ago one of the most
progressive civilizations on earth was
that of the Muslim faith because one
other thing that Quran does that
certainly Christians weren't doing at
that point is they gave women a whole
series of rites it is written into the
Quran how much the wife gets how much
the daughter gets how much the cousin
gets how much the aunt gets of course
men being men they didn't get an equal
share but they got something and that
was completely different from what was
happening out of our places and if we
were designing a system of ownership
today we might say that is probably
better than a system that argues if you
are they first out of the womb and you
have a penis you get everything it
doesn't matter if you study it doesn't
matter if you're a drunkard it doesn't
mean if you work or don't work as long
as you are the firstborn heir that is
male you get it all so for a long time
Islam flourishes and these other
backward things don't and if any one of
us was sitting here in the abstract
thinking of how do you want wealth to be
passed on to the next generations the
first seems like a better method but
there are unintended consequences to all
this stuff so one of the unintended
consequences of what happened is when
you started getting these big voice
where it took a lot of money in three
years to bring the spice back or to
bring the silk back or stuff in the
British system if one of your 20
partners died you had 20 partners but in
the Islamic system if one of your
partners died all of a sudden you had
another hundred partners and then the
next one died and you had another
hundred partners it was very hard to
accumulate capital to maintain
corporations to maintain a whole series
of things and the British system
absolutely inequitable as it was built
up a completely Efrain economy while the
other one collapsed patents in things
like life are a complicated road to walk
there are people who are passionate
saying no or yes take the example of
Canada there are few countries and
people who are as nice as Canadians as
long as you're not playing hockey and
one of the things they did is they went
out and they said we shouldn't patent
life well that makes a great deal of
sense now the only problem is this
wonderful guy at Harvard called Phil
leader had built something called a
Harvard Mouse any patent of the Harvard
Mouse why would you patent the mouse
because it's a mouse that's built for a
specific purpose to make replicable
types of experiments and it's easy for
that Mouse to get cancer if you want to
test new cancer drugs you want mice that
have the same type of genes to see if
this thing works or doesn't work and you
don't want to wait 20 years for this
thing to get cancer because Canada
didn't patent this stuff one of the
things that happened is very few
companies chose to do basic life science
research in Canada so you can tell me
the names of a whole bunch of Swiss
pharmaceuticals French pharmaceuticals
German pharmaceuticals of American
pharmaceuticals but it is very hard to
come up with Canadian pharmaceuticals
you have to be careful in these debates
it's not often that there are good guys
and bad guys often it's a great
difficult area where you have to
navigate and come up with compromises
well on that you're talking about pharma
big small and not happening another
domain where patents controls
and biotechnology is in agriculture and
so you've got the Monsanto's of the
world and Roundup Ready crops and so on
they're keyed between the the the plants
and the pesticides but you've also got
in Australia in various other places now
in Africa increasingly open source
biotech which is basically working on
plants that really work in South Asia
that really work in Africa that you know
there's no particular market and the
northern hemisphere so Monsanto is not
that interested and they're going at it
in an open-source way you know very well
what's happened with open source in pure
technology how does that map onto all
this you know there's this nasty thing
called competition and it actually works
and I think in an ideal world on the one
hand you do have the Microsoft's and you
do have the Oracles and you do have all
these other creatures that give you blue
screens of death and you have a
competing open-source system and I think
as long as both of those systems are
working and as long as both of those
systems are moving in parallel and
pushing one another all of us benefit I
would not want to see a world where
open-source is a law and the only law
and the only option and I wouldn't like
to see a world that prohibits
open-source that is true of computer
code and that is true of agriculture and
that is true of a whole series of other
things there are people who have
extraordinary talent and they won't
apply it in different ways some people
you know are focused on making a buck
and some people are focused on changing
their world and being cool to their
friends and I'm good for both of them
you know I mean it's it's wonderful to
have that variety in an ecosystem you
don't want to dictate it in one way or
dictate it in the other there aren't
black hats on white hats some can be a
little blacker no names well I think
we're talking about two different kinds
of competition here there's the kind of
competition in war or in sports where
basically the two sides of that kind of
competition become more and more like
each other they have to in order to
compete they're the other they're going
to that slight advantage to win in that
particular game but ecology and
evolution tends to work in the direction
of what's called the competitive
exclusion principle where instead of
going dead at the competition you figure
out a whole different niche and
carefully avoid competition and that's
how you to survive but that's also in a
sense of form of competition is that
what open source is doing in relation to
you know the patent world is just
finding a different niche I hate
answering questions from you you know I
think there's a mixture of stuff there
on the one hand you look for this niche
where nothing will come eat you or
nothing will come destroy you and on the
other hand as you become more and more
successful you keep running up against
these niches where things tend to wipe
you out and again you run into this law
of unintended consequences so you know
you go into hospital rooms and you clean
them all and the better you are at
cleaning them will likely or you are to
get really sick in that hospital so one
of the places where you get really sick
these days is inside the intensive care
units of hospitals why because they swab
everything and of course if point oh one
percent of the stuff survives that stuff
is really tough and it's got an empty
ecosystem and it's got light and it's
got space and it's got food and all of a
sudden you get these antibiotic
resistant bugs that grow quickly and the
irony of some of the stuff is sometimes
the better you try and do things the
unintended consequences get really
complicated as you talk about this open
source stuff the patent stuff doesn't
get my blood boiling for the most part
the copyright stuff does
okay the notion that you can have a life
saving medicine put it on patent for 19
years after you've invested hundreds of
millions I can deal with that the notion
that you change the copyright laws and
put you know nine decades on it and go
beyond the inventors or creators life
because you want to keep the disney
mouse on patent that bugs me like larry
lessig is one of the smartest people
working out there and I hope that people
support the stuff that he's doing a
creative copyright because that's that's
one of the places where the
dissemination of knowledge and the web
is gonna get hurt and that exercises me
much more this it's interesting Lessig
figures he's set the solution for that
problem in motion and he's now moving
into a whole nother area which is money
for political campaigns we're watching
from an interesting
Jonathan Pfeiffer asks have genomics or
pharmacogenomic genomics failed to
deliver on any of their promises and if
so why what when things go wrong what
kind of things go wrong how much time do
you have
I mean look all of us were promised that
you know I remember those covers of Time
magazine the if drug when interference
started coming out and you know now
they've done this so now they've cured
cancer and now they've Dadda Dadda look
every technology tends to get overhyped
and then after it's been overhyped we
say that didn't deliver and then it kind
of goes to sleep for a while now there's
some really smart people working on this
phenomena Paul Sappho has been working
on this on robotics and he keeps telling
me look focus on robots why because for
centuries we thought you know Jetsons
and it didn't happen so we quit focusing
on robots but now you've got an
intelligence coming together with a
processing capacity coming together with
a battery capacity it's going to do some
really interesting stuff and you're
gonna see that in technology after
technology after technology and biotech
is certainly one of them genomics is
going to be one of them and the Human
Genome Project is going to be another
one
hey the human genome has been out there
for six years what's it done for me
lately well it takes 14 years to get
medicine to market and a few hundred
million dollars and that's not good we
should be thinking about that because
often we focus on stuff that's the
immediate and easy to understand this
drug killed 12 people you know what
that's just horrible
what we're going to do about that is
we're going to increase the scrutiny
we're going to increase the size of the
clinical test we're going to put a
couple more years on this drug coming to
market and what we're doing is we're
measuring how those twelve people don't
get hurt again but we're doing the same
thing that Europeans still do which is
to put in place a precautionary
principle prove to me this drug will not
hurt people and I'll let you sell it
proof to me you will never beat your
wife over the next 50 years and I'll let
you marry her you would have very few
drugs coming to market and that's
actually what's really happening today
you've got twenty five to thirty five
new drugs coming to market per year
since nineteen eighty five massive
amounts of investment same number of
drugs complete collapse in productivity
so most pharma companies are now
becoming marketing companies as opposed
to discovery companies and that's really
scary let me give you an example of what
the stuff means when you put the price
of a drug up according to Pharma which I
think is exaggerated at eight hundred
million bucks per drug that goes from
trial to pharmacy what you're doing is
you're making it impossible for drugs
that aren't going to make blockbusters
to come to market and that means you
shouldn't be focusing on these twelve
people who are hurt you should focus on
the two hundred three hundred four
hundred thousand people who are gonna
die of malaria who are going to die of
TB who are gonna die of a whole series
of diseases because it's not profitable
to make those drugs what do you call
that principle if it's not the
precautionary principle what's the name
of that one what's the name of the
principle to focus on the three hundred
thousand who might be held purses the
twelve would be hurt well I think one of
the things we've got to start doing is
start measuring the costs of not acting
as opposed to the cost of acting because
we're taking you know whole bunch of
CEOs sometimes those reason and cause
and sometimes without it into courtrooms
in South Texas where there isn't a rule
that says only one walk yacht for lawyer
okay so you've got these guys flying
into these obscure courtrooms
in G fives because it's the fifth
company that they've sued the pants off
and every time they do that what they're
doing is they're increasing the cost of
drugs and they're making those drug
companies marketing companies right when
you go out and you sell a pill like
nexium your marketing budget is larger
than the marketing budget of Budweiser
beer why because if you have a new but
somewhat risky drug coming to market
would you rather sell that and perhaps
spend the next ten years in a court room
or would you rather sell the hell out of
what you've already got or merge with a
company that is really damaging to the
US it's really damaging to health care
and I don't know what the name of the
principle is but we've got to start
measuring the costs of not acting as
well as the costs of acting we're not
really good at that the proaction Airi
principle you first from Kevin Kelley
for action area just go ahead and try
stuff well that's that raises another
question
okay so we got Pharma becoming more and
more conservative very big it reminds me
a little bit of IBM back in the
mainframe days yep and about that time
big blue was perceived as the enemy the
limiter the hierarchical control system
that only governments and huge
organizations which used to step on the
rest of us and all the rest of that kind
of language which was then what led in
part to the hackers and the hackers led
to the liberation of that technology so
we're going to see biotech hackers any
day now you know I suspect even though I
wouldn't know that there might be one or
two hackers or X hackers in this room
just a thought isn't that a terrible
thing well they you know make weapons
they'll give to the terrorists so it'll
become terrorists is so easy or
something well here's the news for you
hackers who scared the hell out of your
parents your kids job is to scare the
hell out of you
and they're gonna go out and they're
gonna do things with life-forms but
you're gonna walk in and kind of go huh
and stuff evolve well what's the
offshore angle here because in the US
there's all kinds of controls but China
Chinese are relatively relaxed about
things that we get our moral knickers in
a twist about and there's you know
people starting companies every which
way and India the same thing and other
places people catch on to this stuff
pretty fast you were just saying that
you know we are coming up on basically
garage biotech sure so is there going to
be a huge infusion this stuff from
elsewhere in the world
I learned lesson with as the future
catches you when I published that I got
the CBL saying what did you mean on page
37 of the Chinese edition when you argue
dot-dot-dot when I thought I didn't know
there was a Chinese edition so I called
up my publisher and he said there won't
be a Chinese Edition for two months and
when I looked at the front page and it
said copyright which translated into
Chinese of course means right to copy
[Laughter]
you know if the US isn't really careful
a couple of things are going to happen
one is there's a such a huge Delta
between what it takes to research and
bring a medicine to market and what the
regulatory costs burden is on that that
anything underneath that burden these
guys can bring to market for 20 40 or 60
million bucks and that's you know a
delta of about a hundred and twenty
million bucks which is a good delta to
play with as you move towards billion
dollar puck or 900 million dollars
things and what could happen in life
sciences and biotech and pharma if we're
not careful is exactly what happen in
computer chips and what happened in
computer hardware and what happened in
steel and will happen in cars which is
some of these very smart people in China
and India are gonna start making the
stuff and they're gonna underpriced and
they're gonna bring stuff to market
faster better cheaper and right now it
certainly doesn't look like it but then
again in the 60s
look like your panel is going to take
over manufacturing let's go to another
part of this spending the brain science
there's a question from Ron please
comment on the map of the psyche or
mapping of the conscious and unconscious
mind what Carl Jung or Buddha say about
all this you know there are people in
this room who are far smarter than I am
who could answer that question far
better than I could I mean one of the
things that I like to do is I like to
collect sort of the early books and
manuscripts that come out of molecular
biology and one of the really
interesting things is how this
cross-pollination started taking place
so Jim Watson wanted to be an
ornithologist he was out studying Birds
until he read a book by a physicist
called Schrodinger called what his life
so here's a physicist talking about
biology inspiring an ornithologist to
change his profession and one of the
more amusing books that I sort of picked
up is a collaboration by del Brook and
young writing together on these
questions and that cross-pollination
doesn't take place as much anymore but
what would Buddha say and what would
Jung say I wouldn't dare answer that
question okay try this one from Mike
basically he's asking how does biotech
as it affects humans and as it affects
everything else relate to climate change
one of the really interesting things
that happen during a sorcerer expedition
as we started understanding how
prevalent microbial communities are and
how very they are so there's more
variety of ecosystems sitting on the
ocean surface than there is in the
Amazon about seventy-five percent of
what we found every two hundred miles
had never been seen before I put that in
context it means that if you went and
sampled houses every 200 miles in the
u.s. inventory every single thing
seventy-five percent of what you'd see
at the thousand house you'd never seen
before that means that there's a linear
increase in the number of protein
families on earth and the number of
genes on earth that means that about
half the biomass on the planet turns out
to be microbes but there's more carbon
absorption in the oceans than there is
on land that it really matters if a
series of viruses are attacking some of
these animals in the South Pacific
because if they start dying off on a
large scale then that oxygen doesn't
change we are just beginning to
understand the cartography of
metagenomics I'm synapse Lee spectacular
adventure as we begin to learn these
carbon capture mechanisms these other
mechanisms they may turn out to be just
as important as some of the other stuff
that we're doing or not doing I don't
know the answer but it sure as hell fund
it sail to the South Pacific to try and
find out well a big part of the climate
change story is is energy you touched on
that a little bit it sounds like this is
an area you're personally putting time
and investment into you want to say a
little more about biotech and energy
without BP and your company doing for
example well I mean think about
agriculture for a second what what
happened in agriculture for centuries is
we use brute force on so we went out and
we built bigger tractors we built bigger
harvesters we built bigger con lines we
built a huge fertilizer factories we've
built herbicide factories so it was this
little plant and throw more stuff at it
bigger combine is better than a smaller
combine of course in the 1960s we
started to change our chemical
mechanical approach
to agriculture and started working on a
biological approach and all of a sudden
you quit having famines in China and
India and China and India became net
grain exporters thanks to one of the
greatest heroes on this planet Norman
Borlaug and it's incredible that we
don't recognize Norman Borlaug for
having fed more people and stopped more
famines than any other single human
being alive I think what's going to
happen in energy is something similar if
we start thinking of energy as
concentrated plants or concentrated
bacterial matter that is absorbed and
frozen sunlight all of the mechanical
approaches we've been using to generate
energy have a bigger deeper platform
have more of the drilling fluid have
more pressure in the will all this brute
force stuff that is really reaching it's
sort of top in the Alberta tar sands for
extraordinary operations in scale and
brutality are gonna start changing as we
learn how to do things like fertilize
oil wells or fertilize coal seems to see
the reason why some coal mines explode
and other coal mines don't it's because
there's a lot of gas in this one and not
in this one and the reason there's gas
is because probably there's bacteria in
in they're eating frozen plant matter
and they do exactly what a kid who's
eating a plate of beans does they
generate a lot of gas and if you can
take the gas out of coal without having
a straight line up or without having to
process it and burn it in the plants
that are the single greatest source of
single point emission for greenhouse
gases that's a good outcome as you
transition into things like solar energy
as you transition in a wind as you
transition to tide all these things that
are staying out there but you need a
bridge to that and that bridge isn't
ethanol I'm very conscious of your time
that you've been here for an hour and a
half let me take one last question all
right and I like your company is going
to be bottling Kuti farts
this is from Robin Hatton that name how
to be a good Explorer this territory
what should a kid in college study today
biology computer science molecular
physics philosophy what it makes
absolutely no difference whatever you
study is going to be obsolete right so
what is that leave what do you do about
four years or whatever look I mean take
a poor radiologists radiologists used to
be the king of images and what's
happened over the last decade as
radiologists and now take 25% of the
images in a hospital because all of a
sudden the heart people are ear imaging
the heart stuff then there's these
people imaging the brain and there's
people imaging the fetus then there's
people imaging this that and the other
and all of a sudden this nice
well-defined field has 75% of people who
were outside the field who were now
playing what's really wonderful about
today is a fortune 500 company used to
last about 94 years as a fortune 500
company
now they last about 14 years that means
that whatever your kids study today is
gonna be obsolete in about a decade
and as long as they're curious as long
as they have the discipline to learn as
long as they know how to triage
information as long as they understand
that they're moving from a world where
there are you know specific rules and
things you've got to learn into a world
where you just got to keep learning and
they consider that a great adventure
then you can have a very successful
country and you can have successful
companies and it's keeping and learning
and teaching this curiosity and doing so
with the same discipline that you apply
to football
that will make countries great and
survive thank you all very much
muchos Gracias
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]